salehi on est mercredi aujourd'hui pour
cette messe qui se joue sans même en
avoir un peu de sélections au marché
les hommes 15-49 est à la question que
vous posez on espère simplement des
mathématiques
lactique multiplication tu vas avant de
donner des nouvelles pour la stib
mercredi j'avais simplement envie de
vous parler multiplication juridique les
multiplications délicat ce que
c'est que ce sont les indiens qui
hantait cette méthode parce qu'il faut
quand même savoir que les indiens quand
je dis les indiens jeudi des hindous
bien sûr que je parle pas de ceux qui
sont de l'article les interrompre tout
simplement créé le système numérique
actuelle avec les chiffres la panne a
fait c'est même eux qui ont créé le
cerro sa part confirmé marc réussir au
pc normes si énorme que ce qu'ils ont
réussi à symboliser leur égard et ça
ça ouvert des portes à plein de choses
on s'en reparlera
si ça vous intéresse ici c'est les
intéresse pas j'en reparlerai port ils
ont précisé les mathématiques telles
qu'on les connaît aujourd'hui ils ont
fait le plein de choses pour nous don
une chose un peu oublié les
multiplications teddy que vous en avez
peut-être déjà vu aujourd'hui je vais
vous expliquer comment les faire ce sont
les multiplications que l'on fait en
dessinant des calculs plus on estime
qu'il ya deux types de multiplication
des pixels qu'on dessine il note
méthode qui consiste à poser le
calcule plus en reparlerai peut-être
dans l'un des masterclasses du du samedi
mais là on va parler de la version la
plus ludique celle qui consiste à
dessiner des traits pour symboliser les
deux shifts de multiplication si je peux
faire deux choix douteux alors que
disney deux traits pour symboliser le pp
pour dessiner le 12 gfr un prêt pour le
pain
et un peu plus bas je veux descendre un
peu je veux faire de très pour le pays
je crois que c'est clair pour trouver le
résultat j'ai créé des sectaires et
compter le nombre de croisement ça
certains secteurs
et ça c'est un autre secteur
le premier secteur et comporte de
croisement
donc je vais commencer à écrire un but
sitka croisement d'un bon deuxième
secteur
donc ça me fait 4 et deux fois tout ça
fait bien 24e je sais que vous le
sachiez bien qu'aucun problème avec la
question étant plus compliqué avec
treize fois par terre attention
apparition très souriante a fait un bon
exemple pour vous expliquer comment on
fait avec des nombres à deux chiffres
donc montréal je vais le tester mais
comme ça
après pour le point
trois entrées pour le 3
et mon mandat je dessine
perpendiculairement par rapport à un
compromis nombre
donc tous les deux
les filles pour le de bakker et pourtant
ici pour un père à chaque fois vous
devez placer le deuxième membre
perpendiculairement d'en retracer ligne
sinon y'a pas de croisement forcément
j'identifie les secteurs touchés par la
diagonale la chambre par ici
là j'en ai plein
hélas je m'efface ici maintenant j'ai
plus qu'à compter le nombre de
croisement qatar secteur y a qu une
seule règle à respecter il faut partir
du bas peuple vers le haut du dernier
chiffre au premier comme ça si à une
retenue à la basse intégré
automatiquement je pars du bas un deux
trois donc ça finira par an 3 celui du
milieu un deux trois quatre cinq six et
à fait voilà ici ayant obtenu donc
très soit 21 ça fait bien de 173 vous
en fait un autre un peu plus compliqué
pour vraiment vous puissiez bien
comprendre et on va dire
42 je ne savais même pas si j'aurai
cette classe pour que ce soit bien clair
là ça commence à être un partage les
entoure on voulait faire voir mais
après quand le fait
ce même on n'a même plus besoin de les
entourer
deuxième secteur
celui-ci
et enfin troisième secteur
celui-ci c'est un peu fouillis sommes un
petit quart d'heure à jouer je compte
du bas vers le pot donc le parfum de
trois personnes 6 7 8
j'ai même honte parce que le pain de 3
4 et 6 7 8 9 ils seront peut-être pas
tout à fait il fait 18 9% au capital de
cfao que je mets le monde ici
et moi je retiens deux
pour le secteur suivant comme ça je
compte m'en sépare compter
trois personnes qui s'exécute on est
assez dense
et je rajoute mans 14 ça c'était
vraiment pour vous faire voir
l'importance de compter du bas vers le
procope ça vous avait injecté aux
tenues comme ça dans les bus
directement moi je ne te suis je sais
pas comment font les autres
je note maintenant retenue au-dessus de
la bulle correspondante ça marche
évidemment et que tous les membres
pouvait multiplier dénombra à trois
chiffres par des membres à deux
chiffres ce que vous voulez c'est
toujours la même litanie suffit de
dessiner et de bien entourer ces
secteurs
pour commencer ça permet de ne pas se
perdre
et de prendre le temps de comtés après
avec son doigt en fait plus de calcul à
faire c'est que du comptage en réalité
qu'un petit dernier pour la route disons
deux cent cinquante trois fois à cinq
vous avez bien compris qu'à chaque fois
qu'il se passe entre chaque chef-lieu
âgées 253 l'écrit bon la grecque
aucune difficulté à trouver les
secteurs donc sur le premier on atteint
2 3 4 le pilote de captage
p je vais
une retenue de faim dans le secteur
d'après vingt-cinq pompiers et un
passif
et j'ai deux dans cet ordre 1 2 3 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12
253 fois c'est un truc ça fait bien
1965 et là vous comprenez en quoi la
méthode des boucs c'est que maintenant
il est plus à calculer il a simplement
raconté il ya jusqu'à 18 accusés a
compté comme ça avec son doigt
c'est très intéressant pour les as du
social décent pour les enfants de leur
apprendre ça dans certains pays je
crois qu'on leur apprend maintenant que
je sais qu'il aime et que le chinois zte
et méthodologies maintenant qu'ils
utilisent les multiplications des dykes
partager cette vidéo ça peut servir à
plein plein de monde c'est l'astuce du
mercredi pour l'emmental blog
abonnez-vous à la chaîne abonnez-vous
sociale quand même
on s'approche de l'objectif de 1500 à
2500 abonnés pour se retrouver à
pareille par caméra interposée entre
poire le parler directement de pétards
de mentalisation parler des astuces
parler de tout ça sans mentalisme de
marquette tourné cette vidéo
abonnez-vous à la chaîne et
rendez-vous demain à 17 heures au
prochain mandat le lock out